there's been speculation about another
jackass sequel since the credits rolled
on jackass 3d in 2010 that last
incarnation of the gross-out prank fest
was so popular the paramount released
jackass 3.5 a year later which was full
of unrated and outtakes from 3d but fans
still haven't had their fill of the
death-defying stunts and excrements
centered pranks they've grown to love in
the first three movies in the six years
since jackass 3.5 there's been a ton of
buzz about the next installment
Paramount Pictures supposedly registered
a bunch of jackass 4 related domain
names Johnny Knoxville said in a reddit
AMA that there were no plans for another
movie but they were open to doing
another director Jeff Tremaine announced
it would be shot in Australia and Bam
Margera even let it slip that they were
toying with the Jackass sequel named in
honor of the crews late buddy Ryan Dunn
talking about it we're not done yet like
do you and
so why hasn't another sequel happened
yet is there a worldwide shortage of
tasers and poo cannons that were unaware
of not quite here's why we never got to
see jackass for Johnny Hollywood though
the show and movies were definitely a
collaborative effort Johnny Knoxville
has always been the point man for the
wild jackass crew as the de-facto host
of the show Knoxville brought a certain
star quality that helped transform what
were essentially underground skate
videos into a multi-million dollar TV
and film concept between the first two
Jackass movies Knoxville made the jump
to actual films with starring roles in
the wringer and the Dukes of Hazzard
reboot and yes he still returned for
jackass 3d but he's also talked about
the desire to make films with a
narrative in 2017 Knoxville completed
such a film which he described the
complex as not jackass but all the
stunts are done in the vein of adding
it's a scripted film with me doing the
stunts that film is action Park and it's
based on a real New Jersey theme park
that had a notorious reputation for its
lack safety policy that resulted in many
cases of guest injuries and even six
deaths during an interview on Jimmy
Kimmel Live Knoxville listed the litany
of injuries he suffered while shooting
action park two concussions a broken
hand sprained knee torn MCL I got
stitches on this side but that wasn't
even the worst of it but I gave up the
emergency room for my second concussion
and I blow my nose and when I blow my
nose my left eye pops out of its socket
so while Knoxville clearly still has the
itch to perform crazy stunt work it also
seems like he wants to tell a story to
star schedules with Knoxville's career
more or less taking off the rest of the
guys have had to turn to other venues to
keep the paychecks coming in steve-o is
busy nurturing a fledgling stand-up
comedy act while Chris Pontius wee man
Preston lacy and Dave England have
basically taken the Jackass concept and
applied it to a live show in 2016 they
went to Australia with their filthy cepo
tour and on stage mix of stunts and
comedy routines but for the most part
they seem to be just biding their time
until the next Jackass reunion brings
them all back together in an interview
with The Daily Journal Preston lacy
admitted that the next Jackass sequel
hinges in
hi early-on Knoxville's involvement
hopefully we'll do another movie we're
just waiting on Johnny Knoxville
schedule in Hollywood unless you have a
contract nothing is nothing
Stevo seemed to have the same sentiments
but he put it a lot more bluntly he told
Uproxx some of the guys are sort of less
busy than other guys and kind of feeling
really desperate to get another movie
going every once in a while an email
will be sent to everybody from one of
the guys in the cast saying come on come
on let's make a movie let's make a movie
it seems like a pretty clear sign that
without Johnny Knoxville's involvement
that movie will probably never get off
the ground a dark cloud Ryan Dunn's
tragic loss in a drunk driving accident
came right on the heels of the release
of Jackass 3.5 and had a devastating
effect on the Jackass crew Dunn and his
passenger Zachary Hartwell fatally
crashed when done lost control of his
Porsche which he was reportedly driving
between 132 and 140 miles per hour
his blood alcohol content was 0.196 at
the time of the crash both director Jeff
Tremaine and Johnny Knoxville pin
touching tributes to their fallen friend
on Knoxville's blog in tremaine's entry
he writes he was such a huge part of our
family and it has forever changed
without him Dunne was also Bam Margera's
best friend and Margera later admitted
that he'd spiraled out of control after
Dunn's death during an episode of Family
Therapy Margera said since Dunn got in
that crash everything changed
dramatically and instead of drinking for
fun with your friends it turned into
drinking to forget while a sequel is
still possible the loss of a beloved
friend and cast mates certainly cast a
dark cloud over any future jackass
project Margera's sobriety after Dunn's
fatal accident Bam Margera's drinking
spiraled out of control leading steve-o
to express his doubts over whether
Margera can even get himself together
for a sequel in a 2016 reddit AMA he
said if Bam can stay sober and healthy I
suppose it's possible but I think it's
unlikely meanwhile it seems like Margera
is ready to throw himself back into some
kind of chaotic prank filled atmosphere
in an interview with the gorilla flicks
blog Margera opened up about getting
healthy refocusing on skating during a
lengthy European hiatus and possibly
getting another installment of jackass
going he's even got a concept ready to
go which he's tentatively calling
jackass hotel which would trick the
entire cast into thinking they're
checking into a hotel to start shooting
the movie only the hotel is already
rigged with cameras and pranks
explained the concept saying before they
know it we just filmed the movie without
anyone's knowledge we with everybody
every room is rigged everybody's there
to prank everybody prank after prank
after prank but aside from the fact that
he basically ruined the possibility of
that concept by talking about it Margera
doesn't even seem that committed to the
Jackass brand anymore he closed the
interview saying dear Tremaine let's
figure out something to film again
whether it's a jackass or something else
I like this new vice LAN channel and I
have a couple ideas so I'm ready to film
again I've spent a lot of time sitting
at bars and drinking but I'm over that
now I've had enough steve-o isn't
interested
for his part steve-o seems like he's
just plain moved on from the show and
movies have made him famous the star
famously battled his own addiction
issues during the show ketamine PCP
cocaine nitrous nitrous oxide but he's
since cleaned up and he told The Daily
Beast that on top of focusing on his new
stand-up career he's also searching for
a new purpose in his life now my goal is
to find separation between me and that
character to find separation between
steve-o and whoever I am and more than
that for whoever I am to find fulfilment
and validation from within that's a big
turnaround for a guy who wants to have
headfirst into Mike Tyson's fist just
because he could
but fans don't have to worry too much
about the possibility of a steve-o less
jackass for since he also told Vice I
almost don't want there to be another
jackass movie because I've worked hard
to build my own momentum and for me to
have a little bit of traction and to be
able to be getting away with having a
career beyond jackass I want to keep
that going but I would never turn down
anything jackass related aging out hard
to believe but Johnny Knoxville is now
closer to 50 than 40 and in the two
decades that Knoxville battered his body
for the show and movies he's racked up
innumerable injuries once after getting
viciously head punched by Butterbean and
once after flipping a golf cart steve-o
brought up the cold hard truth about
Aging in an email to his buddies hey I
loved working with you guys we're all
great friends it's something really
special that we have but with that set
as excited as I am to work with you guys
if we're going to another project we
need to figure out a way to get out in
front of it and acknowledge we're all
because we're old and even though he's
not exactly thrilled with the prospect
of aging he also told the Daily Beast
now I'm in my 40s and I can't post a
picture without someone commenting dude
you got old I think I'm pretty realistic
about it it just points to what's
important is to find separation from
that director projects Jeff Tremaine is
the director and driving force behind
Jackass his skate magazine big brother
served as the inspiration for the show
and even employed almost the entire cast
before they ever had a deal with MTV I
could make a TV show out of it and MTV
just loved it you know they ordered the
series and because hanging out with a
notorious bad boys is kind of tremaine's
thing he parlayed his Jackass success to
tell the story of the world's most
notorious rock band Motley Crue in 2016
he produced a documentary about the
band's final tour and recently announced
that he's finally been attached to
direct a feature biopic about the band
called the dirt Tremaine told screen
crush dirt is something I pursued with
everything I had I've wanted to make
this going back to 2001 when we were
just planning the first Jackass movie
outside of the Jackass Fear Tremayne has
been chained to the skater prank show
John rrah with producer credits for
Nitro Circus
Dudesons in America Rob Dyrdek's Fantasy
Factory and ridiculousness but it seems
he's ready to take a legitimate seat in
the director's chair
plus as far as we can tell the 2014
Daily Mail interview was the last time
Tremaine even spoke to the press about
another Jackass installment sounds like
he's in no rush to get back to it and
without Tremaine behind the camera jack
four will probably never happen hello my
name is Johnny Knoxville I'm about to
end this movie thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]